este es walter el pingüino y walter se
aburre en antártica así que le gusta
correr saltar y deslizarse por la capa
de hielo hasta detenerse pero walter es
un pingüino muy inteligente y muy
curioso y mientras se desliza él piensa
en la conservación de la energía y él
está confundido ya que sabe que comienza
a deslizarse por acá y va a tener cierta
energía cinética pero sabe que va a
terminar por acá sin nada de energía
cinética y él se pregunta cómo es que se
conserva la energía cuando parece que
pierde energía cinética si nosotros nos
hubiéramos hecho esta pregunta cuando
estábamos viendo fuerzas nosotros nos
hubiéramos dado cuenta que a este
pingüino pierde velocidad porque aquí
hay otra fuerza de fricción entre el
pingüino y el hielo quizá esta capa de
hielo es bastante resbalosa pero no está
completamente libre de fricción si fuera
así el pingüino seguiría moviéndose por
siempre también es posible que haya algo
de resistencia al aire que esté
deteniendo al pingüino pero la mayor
parte del movimiento se va en la
fricción pero
y estamos hablando de la conservación de
la energía así que cómo podemos poner
esta idea en términos de energía pues lo
que hacemos es decir que esta fuerza de
fricción va a realizar un trabajo
negativo en este pingüino y sabemos que
es un trabajo negativo porque esta
fuerza de fricción se dirige en sentido
contrario al movimiento del pingüino así
que podemos usar la fórmula de trabajo
para cualquier fuerza efe por de coseno
de teta y si queremos conocer el trabajo
realizado por la fuerza de fricción
ponemos la magnitud de la fuerza de
fricción aquí en nuestra fuerza
multiplicada por la distancia que se
deslizó el pingüino hasta llegar a
detenerse con dirección a la derecha
multiplicada por este coseno de teta y
recordemos que theta es el ángulo que se
forma entre la fuerza y la dirección del
movimiento así que el pingüino se
desliza a la derecha y esta fuerza se
dirige a la izquierda y quizás ustedes
piensen que este ángulo es de 0 pero no
es así piensen que el ángulo entre la
izquierda y la derecha no es de 0 sino
de 180 grados
que este ángulo será de 180 grados o de
pi radiales y el coseno de 180 grados
nos va a dar menos 1 así que el trabajo
realizado por la fuerza de fricción en
este pingüino va a ser de menos fk de la
fuerza de fricción negativa multiplicada
por la distancia en la que se deslizó el
pingüino hacia la derecha pero esto no
responde a la pregunta de walter de a
dónde se fue la energía cinética la
fricción pudo haber realizado trabajo
negativo en el pingüino pero a donde
terminó esa energía y que esa ustedes se
den una idea de en donde terminó esta
energía ya que cuando dos superficies se
frotan entre sí alguna de esta energía
de movimiento se va a transformar en
calor en energía térmica en ambas
superficies en otras palabras esta
superficie helada va a tener un poquito
más de energía térmica y también el
plumaje de wolters se va a volver un
poquito más caliente va a ganar un poco
más de energía térmica así que
terminarán con más energía térmica de la
que
cuando comenzaron igual que cuando nos
frotamos las manos vigorosamente en esos
días de frío para poder calentar las un
poco transformamos algo de energía
cinética en energía térmica y quizá
ustedes me digan bueno esto está muy
bien pero como pongo esto todo junto
tengo esta idea de trabajo por aquí y
tengo esta idea de energía cinética por
acá que marco de referencia me permite
unificar todo esto pues va a ser el
enunciado de la conservación de la
energía podemos decir que la energía
inicial de cualquier sistema más
cualquier trabajo externo que afecte a
este sistema tiene que ser igual a la
energía final del sistema en otras
palabras podemos decir que el pingüino
walter comenzó con la energía cinética
un medio de m por b al cuadrado y aquí
no tenemos que preocuparnos por la
energía potencial gravitacional ya que
aquí walter no está en ninguna elevación
está a ras del suelo y podemos agregar
el trabajo externo que está siendo
realizado por la fricción
- porque es un trabajo negativo efe ks
borde nuevamente es negativo porque este
trabajo le está quitando energía al
sistema y esto debe ser igual a la
energía final pero aquí y walter termina
con nada de energía cinética así que
aquí no tenemos energía cinética al
final y en este caso nos encontramos
algo curioso tenemos que un medio de m
por b al cuadrado va a ser igual a fk
por de la energía cinética con la que
comenzó walter es igual al trabajo ya
que sumamos efe cabe en ambos lados de
la igualdad es igual a la magnitud del
trabajo de fricción por la distancia
quizá algunas personas no estén de
acuerdo con esto y digan haber un
momento acabamos de decir que terminamos
con energía térmica porque no lo
incluimos en nuestra energía final y la
razón es que en estos cálculos de aquí
suponemos que walter y solamente walter
es parte de nuestro sistema de energía
es
y la energía cinética de walter es la
única energía que estamos tomando en
cuenta es por eso que decimos que al
principio solo tenemos la energía
cinética de walters y esta superficie
congelada es externa a nuestro sistema
no es parte del sistema y es por eso que
la consideramos como trabajo externo le
quita energía al sistema y es por eso
que walter termina con nada de energía
cinética pero hay otra manera de
realizar estos cálculos en lugar de
considerar solamente a walter como parte
de nuestro sistema vamos a incluir
también a la superficie congelada como
parte de nuestro sistema y ahora todos
esos lugares en donde iría la energía
térmica como el plumaje de walter o la
superficie congelada entonces ya no
tendríamos trabajo externo una forma
alternativa de resolver estos problemas
es usar esta misma fórmula pero ahora
considerando a walter y a la superficie
congelada como parte del sistema nuestro
sistema sigue iniciando con la energía
cinética que tiene walter al inicio esto
no cambia pero ahora no voy a tener
trabajo externo y no
porque no esté ocurriendo la fuerza de
fricción aquí la seguimos teniendo pero
ahora es una fuerza interna es algo que
ocurre entre los objetos de nuestro
sistema y como ahora tanto walter como
el hielo son parte de nuestro sistema no
tendremos ningún trabajo externo y quizá
esta idea pueda confundir a algunas
personas pero digamos que si existen
fuerzas que ocurren entre los elementos
de nuestro sistema entonces esas fuerzas
no van a ejercer trabajo externo por lo
que no van a cambiar la energía total de
mi sistema solo aquellas fuerzas que
vienen de fuera del sistema y que lo
afectan son las que nos pueden modificar
la energía del sistema cuando este hielo
no era parte de nuestro sistema estaba
realizando trabajo externo en nuestro
sistema por lo que la energía de nuestro
sistema cambió
comenzamos con energía cinética y
terminamos sin energía pero ahora que
tanto walter como el hielo son parte del
sistema esta fuerza de fricción ya no
será externa es una fuerza interna
que se está ejerciendo entre elementos
del sistema no realiza trabajo externo
sino que es solamente va a transformar
energía entre los elementos de nuestro
sistema
por eso escribimos este cero aquí no hay
trabajo externo al menos cuando nuestro
sistema incluye tanto a walter como a la
superficie congelada y esto tiene que
ser igual a la energía final y sabemos
cómo termina comenzamos con energía
cinética pero vamos a terminar con
energía térmica extra tanto en walter
como en el hielo así que esto lo escribo
como energía térmica y si quiero conocer
cuál fue la cantidad de energía térmica
generada pues ésta va a tener que ser
igual a la cantidad de trabajo realizado
por la fricción así que aunque el
trabajo de la fricción no es externo
sigue transfiriendo energía entre los
objetos de nuestro sistema así que
cuando escribimos que el trabajo aquí
era - fk por d nos referíamos a qué
la fuerza de fricción quitaba fk por de
de algo y lo transformaba en otra cosa y
eso es lo que necesitamos aquí
necesitamos una expresión para la
energía térmica así que si la fricción
quito efe acá por de de algo pues lo
transformó en energía térmica justamente
esa magnitud del trabajo realizado es lo
que me da la energía final cuánta
cantidad de energía termino como energía
térmica y quizá algunas personas se
confunden y me digan a ver por qué
terminamos con esto positivo en lugar de
negativo bueno en esta fórmula del
trabajo el signo negativo significa que
estuvo quitando energía del sistema si
le quitamos energía a algo entonces
vamos a estar realizando trabajo
negativo si yo le doy energía a algo
entonces estaré realizando trabajo
positivo así que en este caso el signo
negativo solamente indica que se tomó
esta cantidad de energía y se transformó
en otra cosa que fue energía térmica así
que aquí arriba cuando queremos saber
cuánto fue
energía térmica con la que terminamos
pues resulta que terminamos con la
cantidad que quitamos quitamos
efe cada vez por lo que la energía
térmica terminó con efe k de y esto
sigue siendo igual a la energía cinética
con la que comenzó walter un medio m por
b al cuadrado por lo que terminamos con
la misma fórmula que teníamos por acá ya
que estamos en el mismo universo y en la
misma situación así que no importa cuál
de estas aproximaciones usemos al final
deberemos terminar con la misma física
algunas personas prefieren una en lugar
de la otra a algunas personas les gusta
pensar en la fricción como una fuerza
externa que quita energía como un
trabajo externo negativo por lo que no
incluyen la energía entre las
superficies como parte del sistema y
algunas personas les gusta incluir estas
superficies como parte del sistema y por
eso incluyen la energía térmica como
energía final del sistema lo cual está
bien pueden usar cualquiera de las dos
pero no usarlas al mismo tiempo ya sea
que las superficies forman
del sistema y las incluimos en nuestra
energía final o no incluimos a las
superficies como parte del sistema y
terminamos con trabajo externo pero no
podemos decir que tenemos trabajo
externo y además terminamos con energía
térmica ya que esto forma parte del
sistema o no forma parte del sistema en
pocas palabras ustedes pueden pensar en
la energía térmica generada por la
fricción como fk de esta es la fórmula
que nos permite calcular la cantidad de
energía térmica generada cuando dos
superficies se frotan entre sí y podemos
llevar más lejos esta idea la fuerza de
la fricción cinética va a ser igual al
coeficiente de fricción cinética
multiplicada por la fuerza normal entre
las dos superficies así que podemos
reescribir este término de la energía
térmica como muca por fm por d y quizá
ustedes me digan caray esto luce peor
que como estaba antes pero si
continuamos se darán cuenta que la
fuerza normal de algo que se encuentra
sobre una superficie va a ser igual a m
por g lo seguimos multiplicando por la d
pero ahora que reemplazamos la fuerza
normal con m por g vemos que las masas
se cancelan y esto debería sorprenderlos
significa que no importa cuál sea la
masa de este pingüino si comienza con la
misma rapidez con la que inicia otro
pingüino que puede ser más masivo o
menos masivo que éste se van a deslizar
exactamente la misma distancia y quizá
alguien diga a ver cómo es esto posible
un pingüino más masivo va a tener más
inercia y cómo querrá seguirse moviendo
pues se va a mover más lejos pero otras
personas dirán no no no no no el
pingüino menos masivo es el que se va a
deslizar más lejos porque tiene menos
fuerza de fricción pero justamente por
eso es que no importa qué masa tengan
ambos efectos se van a cancelar
mutuamente en otras palabras el pingüino
más masivo efectivamente tendrá más
inercia pero también tendrá mayor
fricción y el pingüino menos masivo
tendrá menos inercia pero también tendrá
menor fricción así que las masas
terminan cancelándose y todos los
pingüinos sin importar qué masa tengan
si comienzan con la misma rapidez se van
a desplazar la misma distancia y eso
significa que también los automóviles si
tenemos un automóvil pequeñito un smart
y otro automóvil enorme no sea una
camioneta si tienen las mismas llantas
tendrán el mismo coeficiente de fricción
y si comiencen con la misma rapidez y
pisan los frenos ambos se van a detener
después de exactamente la misma
distancia nuevamente muchas personas
pensarán que la camioneta más grande se
va a deslizar más lejos pero esa
camioneta que tiene más inercia también
tendrá mayor fricción por lo que se
detendrá a la misma distancia que él
más pequeño que tiene menor inercia pero
también menor fricción así que mientras
el coeficiente de fricción sea el mismo
para ambos autos la fuerza de fricción
será mayor para el auto más grande para
resumir esto vamos a hacer un ejemplo
quitamos todo esto y ahora tenemos esto
digamos que walter se vuelve más
aventurero y ahora se va a deslizar
desde lo alto de esta rampa que está
completamente congelada y por lo tanto
no va a tener fricción y walter no tiene
miedo así que se lanza desde lo alto de
esta rampa que tiene una altura de 4
metros comienza en reposo y walter
comienza a deslizarse hacia abajo
aumentando su velocidad pero ahora llega
a la sección que sí tiene fricción y
walter se desliza por acá en cierta
distancia de hasta que se detiene y si
sabemos que walter comenzó con una
altura de 4 metros y el coeficiente de
fricción en esta sección es de punto 2
podemos calcular cuál fue la distancia
que recorrió walter antes de detenerse
vamos a resolverlo y vamos a usar la
conservación de la energía
la misma fórmula que vimos anteriormente
que es la energía inicial del sistema
más el trabajo externo realizado en
nuestro sistema es decir la energía que
se agregó o se quitó de nuestro sistema
esto va a ser igual a la energía con la
que terminemos en nuestro sistema ahora
qué es lo que vamos a considerar como
nuestro sistema personalmente me gusta
elegir todo aquello que pueda tener
energía como parte del sistema y de esta
forma no tengo que preocuparme de
trabajo externo ya que todas las fuerzas
serán internas así que elegimos a walter
a la tierra a nuestra rampa al hielo
todo va a ser parte de nuestro sistema y
tomaremos nuestro punto de inicio en
donde vueltas se encuentra en reposo
aquí en la parte de arriba de esta rampa
y nuestro punto final hasta acá en donde
se detiene walter después de deslizarse
con qué tipo de energía comienza a
nuestro sistema bueno walter estaba aquí
arriba y estaba en reposo por lo que no
tenemos energía cinética pero si tenemos
energía potencial gravitacional
mgh nuevamente no tenemos trabajo
externo realizado ya que aunque exista
fricción aquí abajo estoy incluyendo a
esta superficie como parte de mi sistema
lo mismo que el plumaje de walter
entonces no tenemos trabajo externo pero
si tendremos energía térmica generada al
final así que la energía térmica
generada va a ser esta fuerza de
fricción multiplicada por la distancia
en la que se deslizó walter hasta antes
de detenerse al menos la parte que si
tiene fricción así que no voy a incluir
esta parte de la rampa ya que aquí no
tengo fricción solo voy a incluir esta
sección y sabemos que la fuerza de
fricción va a ser el coeficiente de
fricción multiplicado por la fuerza
normal multiplicada por la distancia
recorrida y ya que vuelta se deslizó
sobre una superficie horizontal la
fuerza normal de walter va a ser igual a
la fuerza de gravedad en walter así que
tenemos m g h es igual al coeficiente de
fricción cinética y reemplazamos efe n
mg ya que la fuerza normal es igual a m
por g y esto lo multiplicó por la
distancia nuevamente aquí sucede algo
mágico las m se cancelan walter pudo
pesar 200 kilogramos o 100 gramos y si
hubiera deslizado de todas maneras la
misma distancia ahora voy a despejar de
d va a ser igual a g por h caray resulta
que también se cancelan las g
pudimos haber hecho esto en la luna y no
hubiera importado aunque la aceleración
gravitacional hubiera sido diferente no
hubiera importado
aquí se cancelan así que nos queda que
es igual a h y dividido a ambos lados
entre el coeficiente de fricción
cinética y este es mi resultado ahora le
voy a poner números h es 4 metros y mi
coeficiente de fricción cinética es de
punto 2 por lo que walter se va a
deslizar 20 metros antes de detenerse en
resumen cuando tenemos una fuerza de
fricción actuando en un objeto podemos
usar la conservación de la energía para
tratar a las superficies en fricción
como parte del sistema en cuyo caso
vamos a incluir la energía térmica como
energía final o si no incluimos a estas
superficies como parte del sistema vamos
a incluir el mismo término pero con
signo negativo como trabajo externo
realizado en el sistema pero sin
importar cual elijan la energía térmica
generada en dicha situación va a ser la
fuerza de fricción multiplicada por la
distancia en la cual se deslizó el
objeto